oui c'était important pour moi en cette
semaine où tous les yeux sont rivés sur
Notre-Dame de Paris puisque c'est hélas
le triste anniversaire de l'incendie de
montrer qu'on se préoccupe du sort de
toutes les autres cathédrales de France
en tout cas celles qui sont à la charge
de l'État il y en a 87 dont l'état est
responsable c'est colossal et 87
cathédrales dont il était absolument
nécessaire de relever le niveau de
sécurité on s'est rendu compte après ce
choc de l'incendie de Notre-Dame en 2019
qui avait un besoin de faire des audits
de sécurité sur toutes les cathédrales
et que leur niveau de sécurité était pas
suffisant pas pour toutes donc là on a
mis en place des dispositifs
d'amélioration voler un volet 2 qui
commencent cette semaine pour par
exemple généraliser les caméras
thermiques on a fait des tests à
Beauvais et à Notre-Dame de Paris ces
caméras thermiques permettent de
détecter très tôt des sources de chaleur
inhabituellement élevées détecter aussi
des intrusions et donc réagir plus vite
c'est aussi déployer des colonnes sèches
j'ai pu voir hier à la cathédrale
d'Amiens une colonne sèche c'est une
sorte de gouttière inversée si vous
voulez pour faciliter le travail des
pompiers et l'acheminement de l'eau
c'est aussi le cloisonnement des combles
une cathédrale peut flamber beaucoup
plus vite en cas de sinistre s'il n'y a
pas ses cloisons un peu coupe-feu dans
les combles donc voilà c'est très
concrètement des travaux de ce type donc
là pour l'année 2023 j'engage un budget
de 52 millions d'euros pour restaurer et
sécuriser nos cathédrales ça veut dire
que à l'avenir dans les prochaines
années il sera quasiment désormais
impossible qu'il y a un incendie dans
une cathédrale en France totalement
impossible je rêverais de vous répondre
oui je crois que le risque zéro hélas
n'existe pas totalement mais en tout cas
il sera très très très réduit parce que
là on fait tout pour que ça n'arrive pas
on fait tout pour mieux former aussi les
équipes pour mieux coordonner les
actions entre les pompiers les
collectivités les services de l'État
anticiper tous les sujets techniques qui
peuvent permettre d'améliorer la
sécurité incendie on fait au mieux et
j'espère que ces drames n'arriveront
plus alors effectivement ce samedi cela
fera quatre ans que Notre-Dame de Paris
a connu ce triste incendie où on est la
reconstruction et ce qu'elle sera
atteinte dans les délais
la reconstruction avance au rythme prévu
avec une intensité sur le chantier réel
une passion de tous les corps de métiers
mobilisés sous la houlette tonique du
général Georgelin et je suis confiante
tout le monde est confiant pour une
réouverture à la visite et au culte en
décembre 2024 ce qui ne veut pas dire
que tous les travaux seront terminés je
précise les travaux pourront se
poursuivre mais la cathédrale pourra
rouvrir en décembre 24 donc pas de
cathédrale de Notre-Dame de Paris prête
pour les Jeux Olympiques malheureusement
non mais il y aura énormément
d'expositions d'activités qui vont
montrer par exemple en ce moment je vous
invite à aller voir la réalité virtuelle
cathédrale Notre-Dame éternelle dans le
parking de Notre-Dame qui a été
réaménagée avec une exposition sur le
chantier et une expérience de réalité
virtuelle absolument incroyable à vivre
pour entrer dans la cathédrale comme si
on y était vraiment même se rapprocher
des cloches rencontrer violer le duc
tout est fait pour sensoriellement nous
faire vivre l'expérience de la
cathédrale
[Musique]